now mark McClellan I came here in
December first actually - I had a hard
time sleeping at our time finding stuff
that I was not allergic to my body would
react to a whole bunch of stuff gluten
dairy a whole bunch of different
chemicals just trying to wonder what's
going on I ended up actually finding dr.
Berg's website late at night on a pop-up
ad and it's not before actually but I
just ignored it thinking well just one
of those pop-up ads and I ended up
clicking on it going through the quiz it
was really late but I ended up clicking
and it actually seemed to make sense
next next next if she was gonna close it
out and they're gonna pop up for the
free consultation and they give it a
shot everything they told me it made
sense even though I didn't tell them my
symptoms all the way she was like you
have this and this and this it all
seemed to make sense and really made
sense like came and signed up for dr.
Berg's program and it really helped
change my life it's I've lost 35 pounds
and have been sleeping amazingly have
been eating a lot healthier than I was
before and most of all I've had it
haven't had any any cravings at all for
sugar gluten wheat which is usually I
would have sugar and salt cravings a lot
but with the kale shakes and with the
vinegar drink I and cranberry I haven't
had anything I really feel this has been
a definite improvement just how I feel
and how I live give me a lot more
vitality from what I was before I was
always groggy I was sleeping and during
the day wide awake at night but now I'm
able to sleep at night and actually have
a lot of energy during the day where I
don't even everyone else kind of feeling
dragged groggy and tired and I'm just
wide awake and it's just really cool